hello you welcome to the body coach
hates to here in Richmond is the home of
the 90 day shift shape and sustain plan
transforming lives all over the world
I'm going to give you a little tour cook
up a recipe do a little workout and show
you how it all began I started off as a
personal trainer I used to run boot
camps work with clients on a one-to-one
basis then I created this online plan
and two years later I've got all these
amazing support hero to his staff who
work on the plan and coach people
through the plan I've got business
awards we won the Lloyds best business
of the Year award in 2015 and I've got
loads of amazing things look at this
amazing painting for one so this Drive
came into the office and speed painted
me during a hit session Wayne was doing
30 seconds of exercise 30 seconds of
painting so I'll show you something else
is pretty cool
not many officers can say that they've
got a running track through the office
so when I moved in I thought why not put
this down there get all the staff
training get them up and running and
I've built with gym which they love give
us a wave everyone eats ello so as the
heroes this is where we have our sprint
track leaderboard and we've got press up
leaderboard so people what a to do ten
sprints end to end and you've got we
record our time so dance on thirty three
point four five second it's pretty quick
I'm second of 33.5 two this is the lean
winners of the month so we've got
before-and-after pictures from some of
the clients on the plan really really
inspiring
we like putting those up every few weeks
we change them solar for these skis I
mean how am i you almost have to be a
different person that she's obviously
done really well so okay what I'll do
I'm putting I'm gonna beat my time but
I'll have a little crap I'll do a few
Sprint's show you how fast I really am
sorry ready I want a bit of a cheer and
a clap everybody right
yeah asmath say I'm the fastest man in
the office so come down I want to show a
few more things I've got some really
lovely artwork on the wall this is the
one it's my favorite one Hillier so
throw away the sad step we don't believe
in the scales here the body coach HQ
it's depressing
we take probe's pictures and we
celebrate physical transformation as
opposed to the number on scales so I'll
take you now through to the kitchen I'm
out of breath and I'm gonna do a little
lean a fifty mess with my second book
one of my lovely healthy smoothies so
let's go you've seen the office this is
the kitchen where I do all my famous
leaning 15 videos I'm screaming shouting
hanging out the window I put one of the
quick recipe I'm doing my fax me up
smooth for my first book Lina 15 let's
get cracking so the first thing you want
is some almond milk so you want about
200 mil of that this is a really great
one for breakfast sure in there if
you're in a rush you know you haven't
got much time you want to put your knock
something cup and it contains healthy
fats too so it's gonna give you lots of
energy because we're using half an
avocado chop it all up straight in the
blender we've got a handful of
blackberries can put any berries in
there but you can use frozen ones as
well I've got fresh one so handful of
blackberries handful of blueberries get
in there
we've got the juice of a lime okay so
three squeeze all the juice out one
whole juice of a lime I've got a little
bit of honey so a little squeeze
opponent just half a tablespoon and then
the last thing is some Greek yogurt so
three big tablespoons one two three
stick that in there what's up
that that's my fast mounts movie now I'm
going to take you to the gym next door
and do a lean and 15 workout let's go
right this is the body coach Jim this is
where I do my workouts you might see me
on instagram Facebook YouTube
I've got a few kettlebells and battle
ropes check these out look at these bad
boys [ __ ] tree customized dumbbells
for the body coach hates you because
everyone knows I love little broccoli
I've got some kettlebells some slam
balls few cardio machines what I want to
do now is a quick fire question round
while doing high-intensity exercise okay
I'm ready to go question 1
USA all day long track suit hairy
Nutella tea cake push straight Beyonce
rom-com loose hair obviously cinema
London Bob Christmas gruffly chocolate
guy dive Oh get all day long I really
hope you enjoyed my little toe of the
body coach HQ here in Richmond if you
want to see more videos from glamour
subscribe to glamour UK below and check
out my youtube channel the body coach TV
[Music]